you don't take a loan just to have money
in your bank account but you actually
take the loan as a payment
mechanism a payment method
and in order for a loan to become a
payment method you need technology that
will drive this transaction
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders let's talk
about blender with dr galaviev the
founder and ceo of blender financial
technologies he holds a phd in physics
from nottingham university uk and is a
specialist in quantum optics gal has
over a decade of experience as an
entrepreneur and venture capitalist
i i have to start with the cat out of
the bag
no phd in
nano physics and not just your phd but
yeah
quite a bit of a of spending time there
and then today you're you're running
blender uh
you know a public company here in tasa
and you're you know doing some
phenomenal things in the in the lending
world and changing consumer behavior
when it comes to the ability of people
to to receive funding that they may need
for various reasons um through a single
mobile app across the world
how does one make this transition and
obviously there is a much deeper answer
than the simple question how does one
make the transition from physics to
fintech yeah from from actually becoming
a scientist to move to the business
world and from business world to
actually to
uh to fintech it's it's it was quite
really
it's quite of a transition but i think
that it's uh
mainly relates to
to our passions as people like for me
what's drive us is a big thing um
like
in the world of physics we try all the
time to explore and to understand and
really i think one of the most
important stuff when when you do physics
is you actually understand that you
don't understand is that you understand
almost nothing
and that's okay not to understand it's
okay not to know but you try to find out
the drivers the drive people and drive
systems and in the world of business i
think it's quite the same especially in
the company that is very fast growing
you all the time needs to think of your
clients what drives them what would
bring them to
to use your product and how can your
product be better for them as well
and so walk me through a little bit
about you know you you as yourself you
know as an entrepreneur as an executive
as an academic
you know how how how did you
grow into these fields in their separate
ways
so i uh
i started in a few levels uh
i do sports for many many years i raced
in sailing
for for ages and
got to sail in australia and european
championships and
things like that
and
i'm
a season runner as well i think that
many hours of my week i spend
while running
um it's one of the things that helps me
to clear my mind my mind pretty well
and um
i started physics i think through a
passion i
i
for many years i wanted to to do to do
that and when i started the undergrad i
quite
fairly fast i understood that i want
to go for a master and i want to
specialize in quantum optics it was a
very very special field
um
in the masters i did
i built actually the first quantum bits
that was at the time at room temperature
atom so i took a system that cost over 5
million dollars made it
to less than 20 thousand dollars
and
and then i started a phd and i
was accepted to a phenomenal
lab in in the uk that was doing atom
chips it's
it's means that we actually trapped
atoms really next to a golden beautiful
golden shape very close to it reduced
our temperature to the absolute zero
absolute zero means that there is no
movement and when there is no movements
actually become quantum creatures so
they live in a completely different
world they can
be here and be there in parallel
and um
and behave like a like a quantum
creature and you can really take photos
of them or you can speak with them using
electromagnetic fields
and get the results of their behavior
but in parallel to all that and to very
various experiments that we did from
things that are the early days of
quantum computers to
what happened in the proximity of a
black hole and not in the hawking energy
is that i was working uh
i was all the time fluid around the
world of
investments and venture capital
the first startup i built
was at
2004 i think something like that it was
in medical devices
and then
i moved to investments few years later
and that was all in part to the studies
and i
we i built a company that was actually
investing in venture capital
as in the bridging state
we had involvement in 13 different
companies we actually passed the 2008
which was
quite hectic time for investors
i must say that seven of the companies
succeeded and we made quite a lot
of capitalism that
in
this in investment venture but when i
finished the phd in england at the time
and we came back at 2012 to israel
i
the reason there was this passion to
build something
and from this passion blender came
and we are
a group a wonderful group of founders
it's myself it's my brother which is uh
coming from the technology unit in uh
the of the intelligent crop and
another friend of mine that did together
with me the physics studies the master
and the underground masters and was
doing quant complex systems so this is
barack
and waz is my brother and together we
actually started blender
which is very different and unique
actually from what we saw in the
beginning and it's uh
quite uh you know it's our company but
we feel that it's quite uh
remarkable and fast growing company that
um
all that like for the next things in the
market
to so so you know given the context of
of who you are you know as a person who
you know obviously loves challenges
loves to to to to take on these extreme
you know activities and excel what you
do you're looking right now in the world
of lending and the banking world and how
people
you know get capital um and and it said
it's not trivial it's a you know it's in
you know loans have been around you know
one of the you know for centuries and
thousands of years
where are we at today in the world of
loans even before we talk about blender
how do you see the world of loans before
you
it's not just the world of landing i
think it's the whole world of finance
and fintech i think that this world is
completely changing now and it's rebuilt
from scratch
in all the aspects in all the channels
in all the directions
and
banking are reshaped on a daily basis
and i think that what happening now is a
process of segregation and actually
becoming very good that each of these
companies become very good at specific
channels
uh from
banks as we know them like
all type banks that are trying to do all
in one and actually nothing is really
good to become very specific companies
they're doing something very very well
and we see it
in all the channels so if we go to
trading we have robinhood and we have
etoro and if we have current accounts so
we see revolut and then 26 and if you go
to buy now pay later so you of course
you have klono and a film and you also
have blender there
and if you have deposits so you have
raising and deposit solution so suddenly
we see
financial institutions
many of them holds banking license
but they are very specific
and they bring a true value for the
client at what they do
and i think this is one of the
important aspects here that's this
uh being very specific
very well focused and bring exact the
exact product now when we get to the
world of lending
um
in language there was a a massive change
a massive change if we start to look at
like landing club prosper etc that were
very much you know get unsecured loan
and do something with it
that that is over that is over now
now we are in the in the stage of let's
control our cash flow
let's control cash flow let's bring
products that actually help people
to
uplift themselves
and that means
that
a loan need to be specific for a cause
you don't take a loan just to have money
in your bank account but you actually
take the loan as a payment
mechanism a payment method
and in order for a loan to become a
payment method you need technology that
will drive this transaction at
lightspeed really because the client is
now
in the website in his e-commerce website
is now in the shop
and he needs to pay and live
and for that the
tons of technology around tons
and uh why so so why
why do existing solutions not not allow
for that because loan there are various
loan mechanisms you know primarily
through banking institutions
and you know they understand the purpose
of the loan they understand perhaps why
people need it and they they're they
have the capital to to give it why is
that not enough
i think that there is
so there are two vectors here um
one is the understanding of the client
and
provide the client the exact product
that you need at the exact time
and the second one is the enabler like
to to have the technology and to have
the infrastructure
that would allow you
to create instant instant transaction
that it's actually included risk
and that is a very important point
because to do a money remittance
it's really easy you send money from one
person to another you have something you
need to check of course both of them are
genuine people there are problems around
that but
there is an instant transaction
when you provide a loan
you actually give someone's money and
you give you give money to someone you
actually don't even send the money to
the to the person you send the money to
a shop that is standing at
or that is browsing it
and you presume that you you will get
the money back in
24 payments
from
a person that you never met
that can be in a different country
and you need to have a lot of technology
around it really to understand that
there is a genuine person on the other
side and what is the risk level of the
health of the person that is on the
other side nothing to understand the
risk level and what is his probability
of default
will it would it
yeah that's the issue and it's
complicated
so so looking at the complicated
situation you know there's a lot of
different challenges that you're
presenting here one thing that i'm
hearing here is obviously about trust
and how do you create a mechanism of
trust primarily on the the loner right
the person who's providing the loan
and that has now to to wait for the
capital to perhaps come back and
hopefully not default how how do you see
this consumer behavior shifting you know
for looking at it at a grand scheme of
things you know now you're saying we as
independent people can actually be you
know can actually provide loans and not
just banks what what how how do you
think through this consumer shift
so first of all blender is becoming a
bank across european bank this is uh
this is the next stage of our evolution
so yes we become a bank because
at the end
the cost of capital of banks is the
lowest in the market we you get deposits
and therefore you can provide the best
products for our client and price is one
of
uh one of the questions of our clients
like where do i get
it's not the main question by the way we
were quite surprised that price is not
the main question
the main question is the simplicity of
the transaction
um
and i think that
so you need to have
exactly the product that creates that
right the trust which is
the big part of the of the thing and in
parliament you need to to have the
infrastructure to to allow the
transaction
and why banks do that so much
i don't think that they can be there so
easily it's it's completely different
infrastructure completely different dna
kyc that is not that is immediate in a
few seconds
yeah
you know to open a banking now take you
three weeks not a few seconds
right now now god how does technology
help facilitate
the de-risking of of such a situation
because this is obviously the big
question
and you know a lot of people are talking
about the credit score system of the us
which is the default mechanism for
deciding the validity of a person
person's ability to repay their loans um
but but obviously that's one parameter
out of many possible ones so how does
technology help you leverage
the a variety of parameters to make a
decision here
yes so
when we looked and when we built our
technology and now it's a technology
that ran over half a million people now
so we can really build statistical
models but at the early days
or when we enter to a new country always
there is this question so actually what
you check
so it's relates to
in our perspective in our view there are
first of all is the anti-fraud part so
to understand who the person is really
is
and on the other side is to understand
what is the risk level of the client
right so
the anti-fraud part
we we built a system that is pretty like
we call it the iron dome of anti-fraud
so it's combines
from hundreds of small checks
and we look at the correlations between
these small checks
and this
and it's really strange things that are
being checked over there from things
that we found on the web of the people
they all automated it takes us that a
second
but we accumulate all that together
and that's give us a quite good
picture on the
on whether the person is genuine person
and uh
where he come from and many parliaments
about this person and then to that and
now we move to the other part the other
part relates to understanding the risk
level of the client
and what is his probability of default
and there you use
mainly uh databases so
you wisely said that there are credit
scoring databases uh
various ones so of course we check them
we take actually the road data uh we
don't we never trust the scores we will
always take a lot of the road data and
analyze it ourselves but there are more
and today there is the open banking and
today you can actually get access to all
the transactions that the person is
doing is in his current account
and you can analyze them and you can
really see his behavior his financial
behavior
and that allows the models really to be
much more accurate
and you can also also find which type of
person stand in front of you and to
understand if you want him to be your
client or not because
financing if fintech or this type of
fintech is very strange actually it's
not that you just need to gain the
client
but you actually right after you gain
the client you you need to understand if
you want to give them the product or not
it's i think it's the only field in the
world that you actually
you know you pay the marketing cost the
client gets to you who wants to do the
purchase wait wait wait i'm not choosing
to want to sell
that's one of the problems of fintech in
general
i in incredible now now
if we look at
the world
where blender is you know you're you're
a leading bank and you're and you're
able to provide your services so that
you know you really are creating this
global network of of lenders and loaners
what is the impact
you know in terms of impact of this so
how does this change you know how does
this move the needle in terms of society
or how does this impact people's lives
potentially
yeah so if
it's more a vision question of wait yeah
so in one hand we actually say blender
is becoming across european bank and
right fintech banks it provides but what
this bank provides it provides
lending
and we focus mainly by the way on two
channels on car lending and buying our
pay data
these are the two channels and
after that i will explain and on the
other side we have the depositors
and actually we don't believe that
depositors should get a negative return
for the deposits you know they provide
us the money we use this money in order
to
why they should get a negative return
for that
it's not reasonable
and so right so actually we have
these networks that you speak if here is
actually
if the bank is very focused and is very
focused on a profitable channel
we can accommodate both we can give
one hand to our depositors
the good returns that they are looking
for and for our
borrowers
good pricing in one hand but very fast
and very well
managed
process
borrowing process that would allow them
to
actually to do their purchase and a
purchase can be a car and a purchase can
be
a computer or an iphone it doesn't
matter
right i think that makes a lot of sense
and i have to say that you know it's uh
to me it's always exciting meeting
people and hearing their stories about
how they transition from different
fields and and people that are driven by
challenges and curiosity and i think
that you know when i think about
leadership this is one of those unique
qualities and not obviously your journey
is just a
and putting that as a center focal point
and and i really appreciate your time
and your effort and and i can't wait to
continue following blender's journey and
and at the end you know i'm thinking
about people who who need these loans
and and like you mentioned before people
don't take out a loan to have money in
the bank they take out a loan because
they need it and in today's volatile
world and in today's world where where
at the end money makes the world go
around and as an enabler for a lot of
things
and really you're providing
opportunities for people and so it
sounds like you're making a lot of
positive impact and the company will
continue doing that so thank you very
very much and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]